Hollywood once had a habit of handling superhero
properties poorly, and 1997's Spawn remains
a prime example of that.
Creator Todd McFarlane knows that the first
adaptation was a missed opportunity, which
is exactly why he's going to make certain
the reboot blows you away.
How?
Here's a look.
McFarlane was something of a superhero himself
in the late '80s and early '90s, at least
in comic book circles.
He rose to prominence with his hugely successful
run on The Amazing Spider-Man, co-creating
the anti-hero Venom along the way.
Even Stan Lee was amazed at his abilities.
"We'll try to explain our thinking on how
we're coming across, and why we're doing Overkill
the way…"
"You can think and draw at the same time?!"
Given Venom's massive box office success,
it's no surprise than McFarlane sees possibilities
for the similarly horror-tinged Spawn.
Where Venom opted for a more family friendly
PG-13 rating, though, McFarlane promises to
push the envelope with a truly R-rated superhero
movie.
During an appearance at ACE Comic Con in 2018,
McFarlane said,
"We don't want to muddy the waters, it's R-rated.
Not like Deadpool, where there was just a
couple F-bombs and a naked butt.
Not like Logan either…
We're talking trauma, true trauma, as serious
as possible."
McFarlane even holds out hope that Sony may
choose to distribute the new Spawn film, leading
to a potential crossover between his two creations.
He told CBR,
"No matter who distributes Spawn, the first
thing you will see in every trailer will be,
'From the co-creator of Venom.'
So then my question to Sony is, why would
you let one of your competitors use that line,
given that it was your effort that made Venom
work?...
I think it's worth asking, then, what happens
if they both work?"
Of course, we already know what will happen
if it doesn't work.
"You will be this legless, armless, faceless
thing, won't you?
Rolling down the street, like a turd in the
wind."
Where Venom just had undertones of horror,
though, McFarlane promises Spawn will be pure
terror.
In fact, he told Deadline that his dedication
to a truly dark Spawn film has led to difficulties
with Hollywood execs who don't understand
his vision.
"They all default into their Captain America
mindset and I keep saying, 'No, get into John
Carpenter's mindset or Hitchcock.'
This is not a man in a rubber suit, it's not
a hero that's going to come and save the damsel,
it's none of that."
One way he plans to do this is by abandoning
the tired superhero cliche of presenting an
origin film.
McFarlane told ComicBook.com he plans to just
jump right into the action instead.
"I've seen too many movies that spend way
too much time for the set up."
One way McFarlane is working to deliver on
his many promises is by surrounding himself
with top notch talent.
Producer Jason Blum, who was behind the massive
hit Split, is on board, while superstars Jamie
Foxx and Jeremy Renner are slated to play
the leads.
Yes, leads, plural.
That's because Foxx's portrayal of Spawn will
largely be in a supporting role.
Instead, Renner's brainy cop Twitch will be
at the center of the story, as he seeks revenge
for the death of his daughter while the specter
of the bogeyman Spawn looms in the shadows.
Foxx told Yahoo! that he's sure the final
result will be epic.
"Todd McFarlane is already a badass, but then
you see Jeremy Renner, and you go, 'Wow.'
Because the script revolves around the character
Twitch, and you can look at Jeremy Renner's
face for an hour and a half and be moved.
That's a wonderful partner, and it makes you
feel good about the project."
After what happened the first time he allowed
somebody else to adapt his prized property,
McFarlane understandably wanted a higher degree
of control this time out.
In fact, what the Spawn creator has is essentially
full control; He's writing and directing the
movie himself.
That allows him to go outside the studio system,
where execs are more concerned with moving
tie-in merchandise.
McFarlane told fans at New York Comic Con
2018,
"I don't care about selling t-shirts and hats.
When Spawn comes, it's nice and calm, and
then you're gone.
He will mess you up and he will do it in a
harsh way.
He doesn't care if he's selling any toys or
t-shirts."
These days many superhero blockbusters routinely
cost hundreds of millions of dollars to make.
But the new Spawn reboot is reportedly only
going to cost $10 million, which is just a
quarter of that the original cost way back
in 1997.
How?
According to Blum, neither he nor McFarlane
are taking any pay from the budget, and neither
are the stars.
Plus, they are creating a much smaller, more
contained world, filled with practical effects
rather than CGI.
As part of that, McFarlane hired emmy award
winning Walking Dead director and special
effects guru Greg Nicotero to design the world
of Spawn, including a new costume that is
streamlined for movie audiences.
McFarlane revealed to Fandom,
"We've already designed them, and the great
thing about Greg is, because he's a director,
when I was trying to explain what I was going
to do onscreen visually he could understand
what that meant."
Netflix has had its ups and downs when it
comes to original movies, with hits like Bird
Box and flops like the manga adaptation Death
Note.
Either way, McFarlane told Comicbook.com he
may consider distributing Spawn through Netflix.
"I think the world's changing in front of
our very eyes in how we're going to consume
not only entertainment, but even movies…
I'm not going to get married to a distribution
model that may not be as relevant or as efficient
because that's how you used to do it.
I'll talk to all of them."
If you like the sound of all this, well, you're
in luck, because McFarlane told the crowd
at New York Comic Con that he's actually planning
a whole Spawn trilogy.
"I'm selling it as a trilogy, and each movie
will look different than the last one.
Here's the thing about the trilogy: A lot
of trilogies go back and repeat the last thing.
I want each movie to be visually different."
So why a trilogy instead of a stand alone
film?
"Why do you people always question?
Why ask why?
When how is so much more fun!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.